Générique
...
-Depuis quelques années,
les sportifs de haut niveau
commencent à lancer l'alerte.
Leur santé mentale
est mise à rude épreuve.
-On a la croyance commune
que les sportifs de haut niveau,
en fait,
on est des machines :
des machines à résultats,
des machines physiques,
des machines mentales.
-La recherche de la performance
pousse les athlètes à se dépasser,
et certains finissent par développer
des comportements à risque,
comme des addictions.
-J'ai été beaucoup
dans le surentraînement...
à m'épuiser, finalement,
m'épuiser tant physiquement
que mentalement.
-La parole se libère,
sur les difficultés psychologiques,
mais le soutien proposé
aux sportifs
n'est pas encore
à la hauteur.
-Je dirais
qu'un psychologue par équipe,
ça serait une bonne base
de sécurité psychologique
pour tous.
Musique intrigante
-Alors, comment améliorer
l'accompagnement
des sportifs ?
"Santé mentale :
quand les athlètes vont mal",
c'est le thème de ce numéro
d'"Etat de santé".
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Etat de santé".
C'est un sacré paradoxe.
Ce sont des immenses champions,
de grands sportifs,
qui sont forcément très en forme,
et pourtant,
ils peuvent tomber
en dépression.
Un exemple en France :
Camille Lacourt.
Bonjour, Guillaume Toucoullet.
Merci beaucoup d'être avec nous.
Vous êtes de ces grands champions,
en tir à l'arc.
Je propose qu'on regarde
votre parcours.
-Guillaume Toucoullet
est numéro 1 et recordman mondial
de tir à l'arc handisport.
Ayant perdu l'usage
de son bras gauche
suite à un accident de moto,
il tire avec la bouche
à l'aide
d'une languette en cuir
fixée sur la corde.
Il est un passionné
de sport depuis toujours.
Il pratiquait l'aviron
à haut niveau
avant son accident.
Puis, il revient à la compétition
à peine un an après
en équipe de France handisport
en 2013.
En 2017, il découvre
le tir à l'arc par hasard,
un sport qui devient rapidement
une passion.
En six ans à peine,
il est numéro 1 mondial
et enchaîne les titres
et les médailles.
Sensibilisé aux problématiques
de santé mentale
tout au long
de sa carrière,
il intervient régulièrement
dans les écoles.
-On a compris que vous êtes
un grand champion.
Merci d'être là, car vous préparez
les Jeux Paralympiques.
Donc, c'est un paradoxe.
Le sport, ça maintient en forme,
mais ça blesse aussi physiquement.
Il y a
des grands sportifs blessés.
Et puis,
ça peut atteindre
la santé mentale.
Vous, vous avez été
parfois déstabilisé
au point d'être empêché
dans votre activité ou pas ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Dans la vie d'un sportif
de haut niveau, ou même en club,
on est souvent impacté
par ça, bien sûr.
-"Souvent impacté par ça" ?
Vous en parlez
avec vos collègues ?
-Non, pas trop, car c'est un peu
une marque de faiblesse,
on va dire.
-La santé mentale
des sportifs.
C'est vrai que, pour le coup,
vous êtes là pour en témoigner.
On en parle
de plus en plus.
Il y a des exemples,
effectivement,
qui ont mis le sujet
sur la table.
-En 2021, deux athlètes superstars
ont conduit à lever le tabou
de la santé mentale
dans le sport de haut niveau.
La plus emblématique,
c'est la gymnaste Simone Biles,
quatre fois médaillée d'or
à Rio.
Elle arrive grande favorite
aux JO de Tokyo,
mais en pleine finale
du concours général par équipe,
elle quitte soudainement
la compétition
pour prendre soin
de sa santé mentale
et met sa carrière entre parenthèses
pendant deux ans.
Deux semaines plus tôt,
à Roland-Garros,
la championne de tennis Naomi Osaka
déclare forfait
en refusant de se présenter
aux conférences de presse.
Dans la foulée,
elle révèle souffrir
de dépression depuis 2018.
Depuis, d'autres athlètes
ont suivi,
en mettant ouvertement
des mots
sur la dépression
dont ils souffrent :
le nageur Michael Phelps,
et en France,
l'escrimeuse Ysaora Thibus,
le footballeur Paul Pogba
ou encore le nageur Camille Lacourt.
D'ailleurs,
une enquête menée
par l'association
Comité Ethique et Sport
révèle que sur 1200 sportifs,
80 ont déjà ressenti
de la tristesse
ou un manque de confiance.
Ainsi, parler de ses difficultés
dans le sport
est de moins en moins vu
comme une faiblesse.
L'exemple de Simone Biles
et Naomi Osaka
montre que cela
peut même être une force.
Elles ont repris
le chemin de la compétition,
avec quatre nouvelles médailles d'or
et une d'argent pour Simone Biles,
aux derniers mondiaux
de gymnastique.
-Guillaume,
quand on est un sportif
de haut niveau,
c'est très, très dur,
parce qu'il a fallu
se battre
comme des chiens.
C'est hyper compétitif, en soi.
Ca, ça peut faire mal
dans la tête, non ?
-Ca peut ronger,
bien sûr.
Après, tout dépend
de comment on pratique le sport
et quelles sont nos motivations.
-Et quand vous êtes dans un club,
c'est quelque chose qui est
un peu désamorcé
par les coachs ?
Ils vous en parlent ?
Ils essaient de faire en sorte
que ça ne se produise pas,
ou finalement,
chacun se débrouille
comme il peut ?
-Non,
on se débrouille
comme on peut,
avec ses armes.
Il y a toujours des petites
préférences dans des clubs,
même à petit niveau,
donc on est aussi habitué
à ça, et petit à petit,
au fur et à mesure,
ça peut ronger.
-Le mental d'un sportif,
c'est particulier.
Vous m'avez dit
être rongé par le doute
aux entraînements,
mais pendant la compétition...
-C'est ça.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Je doute beaucoup,
et en fait, le doute me permet
de progresser à l'entraînement.
C'est-à-dire que je remets
pas mal de choses en question.
Est-ce que je suis sûr
de bien faire,
d'être sur la bonne voie ?
Ca, c'est quelque chose...
-Ca ne paralyse pas ?
-Non, c'est un doute
qui permet de progresser.
Par contre,
quand je suis en compétition,
il n'y a plus de place
au doute.
Quand on est en compète...
-On n'y pense plus ?
-Moi, non.
-Tout le monde n'a pas
cette force
que vous avez,
Guillaume Toucoullet.
Alexia Léperon est allée à l'INSEP
pour voir comment le sujet
de la santé mentale
est pris au sérieux
et pris en charge,
et on va entendre
des témoignages passionnants.
-INSEP, à Paris,
le lieu d'entraînement
de nombreux futurs
grands champions olympiques.
Dans l'un des couloirs,
les visages
de la gloire sportive nationale.
Champions multi médaillés,
visages triomphants,
mais aussi une souffrance
qui ne s'affiche pas.
Elise Anckaert est
l'une des rares personnes
à savoir la décrypter,
car psychologue à l'INSEP.
Son travail consiste
à s'assurer
du bon équilibre psychique
des sportifs de haut niveau.
-On peut intervenir
en amont, en prévention,
pour éviter, en fait...
d'arriver
sur des problématiques lourdes
qui auraient pu
être gérées différemment :
éviter, adapter,
en fonction
du parcours de chacun.
Voilà, je dirais
un psychologue par équipe,
ça serait une bonne base
de sécurité psychologique
pour tous.
-Exemple ici, dans le pôle judo
de l'établissement.
-Prêts...
Hajime !
-Madeleine Malonga
est une judokate
qui a enchaîné les médailles :
double championne d'Europe,
championne du monde,
médaillée d'argent
aux Jeux Olympiques.
A première vue,
une réussite sportive sans nuage,
mais moralement,
la réalité est
bien différente.
-On a tendance à se dire,
du moins à croire,
qu'on a des périodes difficiles
que lorsqu'on a des échecs,
mais pas du tout.
Parfois,
on peut même avoir
des victoires
et pas être
vraiment prêt à le gérer.
Moi, je sais
que ma période post-olympique,
après la victoire
de ces deux médailles,
ça a été aussi difficile
à gérer.
Ce qui a été difficile
à gérer,
c'est de retrouver un peu le sens
à ma pratique, car forcément,
je suis partie chez mes parents
à l'âge de 14 ans
pour être championne
du monde, olympique.
Et du coup,
qu'on atteint cela,
après, c'est un peu
comme être au sommet d'une montagne
et de se rendre compte
qu'en fait,
c'est juste
quelque chose de super,
mais que rien ne change
après ça.
-Une remise en cause
d'autant plus difficile à surmonter
qu'elle est dure à avouer.
Le sport de haut niveau
a pour réputation
de ne pas s'attarder
sur les états d'âme
de ses champions.
Pour ces derniers,
se sentir moralement mal
est considéré
comme une faiblesse.
-Dans le judo,
c'est pas quelque chose
dont on parle énormément,
car nous, on a la particularité
de faire
un sport de combat.
Je trouve qu'il y a
cette croyance, un peu,
de si on montre notre vulnérabilité,
c'est comme si on montrait
notre faiblesse.
En fait, moi,
dans cette période-là,
j'ai vraiment appris
que ma vulnérabilité,
c'était vraiment une force,
et pas une faiblesse.
-Pression morale
en cas de victoire,
mais en cas de défaite,
c'est encore pire.
La semaine dernière,
Madeleine a perdu
les championnats d'Europe.
Une déception immense
pour elle,
mais qu'elle relativise
grâce à Elise,
la psychologue.
-Et comment tu vas,
Madeleine ?
-Ecoute, ça va.
Franchement, ça va.
Malgré la déception
et cette compétition ratée,
franchement, ça va.
C'est frustrant,
parce que je me dis :
"Punaise,
j'ai tellement travaillé.
"J'ai tout mis en place
pour que ça marche
"et ça marche pas."
C'est là où il y a
la frustration,
mais je suis convaincue
que ça va marcher à un moment donné.
-On attend beaucoup
du sportif,
et le sportif se met
au service des autres.
Le sportif de haut niveau
aime maîtriser les choses,
avoir du contrôle
sur ce qu'il fait,
et toute vulnérabilité,
en fait, peut être vécue
comme quelque chose
qui peut le fragiliser
par rapport à ses adversaires,
ses coéquipiers
ou ses sélectionneurs.
Voilà.
-On a la croyance commune
que les sportifs de haut niveau
sont des machines à résultats,
des machines physiques,
des machines mentales.
Et ça, en fait,
on le cultive, en plus,
depuis notre plus jeune âge.
On a même cette sensation,
je pense, qu'on sera quelqu'un,
qu'on aura de l'estime
de nous-mêmes et confiance en nous
que lorsqu'on aura des médailles.
Et malheureusement, c'est très dur
d'avoir des médailles.
Quand on n'a pas
de médaille,
on se retrouve un peu...
nu, seul.
Nul aussi, surtout,
et incompris.
On ne sait plus réellement
comment s'identifier.
-On continue. Ca marche ?
-Ca marche, oui.
-Allez, bonne journée.
-Merci beaucoup, Elise.
-Bonne journée à toi, Madeleine.
-A toi aussi. Bon courage.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Dans l'accompagnement
psychologique des sportifs,
l'INSEP fait figure
de bon élève.
Musique émouvante
-Ciao.
-Certaines fédérations
commencent à suivre
son exemple,
mais la santé mentale des sportifs
est encore
trop souvent reléguée
au second plan.
...
-C'est intéressant,
ce témoignage.
-Oui.
-Voilà, ça lui est arrivé,
elle en a parlé.
C'est déjà énorme.
-Oui,
et ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que même quand on gagne,
on peut ressentir la dépression.
Si son objectif est
d'être champion olympique
ou champion du monde,
une fois atteint,
on se demande
quoi faire après.
-Quand on a atteint le sommet...
-Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
-...il n'y a plus rien,
donc on est
complètement désemparé.
-C'est ça,
ça peut arriver.
-Donc l'idée,
c'est que la redescente sur terre
est difficile,
avec un objectif
qui n'existe plus,
quand on est arrivé...
-Si ce n'est de le réitérer.
-Si ce n'est de le recommencer.
-C'est ça.
-Il faudrait s'y préparer.
C'est toujours pareil :
est-ce qu'il y a des sas,
est-ce qu'on est accompagné
pour ça,
quand on est
dans un club de sport,
même professionnel,
au niveau des Jeux ?
-Alors nous,
en handisport,
on n'est pas
comme à l'INSEP.
On évolue
chacun de notre côté
et on se voit
sur des rassemblements.
On n'en parle pas,
mais nos coachs
sont sensibles à ça.
Je peux comprendre
que l'on parte
en dépression
à cause du manque de résultats,
parce que le milieu du sport
à haut niveau, c'est dur.
Dès qu'on fait
des contre-performances,
on voit aussi qu'on est
un peu moins bien suivi,
donc on se dit :
"Je suis nul, en fait.
Il se passe quoi ?"
Et donc, on peut rentrer
dans cet engrenage
et avoir du mal
à s'en sortir.
-Vous êtes
assez remarquable.
Vous êtes champion de tir à l'arc,
après avoir fait
de l'aviron.
-Oui.
-A un moment, vous n'avez pas
été sélectionné pour les Jeux
et vous avez eu un coup.
-Oui,
ça a été dur.
-Vous trouviez injuste
de ne pas être sélectionné.
Comment, vous, vous avez fait,
face à ce revers ?
-Je n'ai pas pu reprendre
à cause de ça, justement.
Ca m'a blessé,
car ça faisait pas partie
de mes valeurs sportives,
donc j'ai arrêté.
-Ah oui, ça vous a dégoûté ?
-Oui, ça m'a dégoûté.
Et donc, j'ai quand même
continué le sport,
et on m'a proposé tir à l'arc
avec la bouche.
C'est un sport
que j'ai appris à aimer.
-Mention personnelle :
avant cette grosse déception
pour les JO,
vous avez eu un accident de moto
qui vous a privé de l'usage
d'une partie de votre bras.
Ce qui est remarquable,
c'est d'être remonté
en scelle.
C'est par le sport
que vous vous en êtes sorti.
-C'est ça.
En fait, j'ai quasiment jamais...
jamais déprimé.
Il m'est arrivé ça,
je l'ai très vite compris,
et pour aller de l'avant,
il fallait mettre ça de côté,
et puis avancer, quoi.
-Ca s'appelle
un mental d'acier,
de façon un peu commune.
Vous avez retrouvé,
en tout cas,
une passion pour le sport,
grâce au tir à l'arc.
Je sais pas
si c'est l'adrénaline,
mais le sport, quand on réussit,
procure des satisfactions fortes,
et parfois, "on tombe dedans",
comme on tomberait dans la coke
ou dans une drogue.
On tombe
dans le sport.
On en parle,
c'est important.
L'addiction au sport
qui touche les sportifs
de haut niveau,
ça peut arriver,
mais aussi beaucoup
de sportifs amateurs.
C'est le reportage
d'Alexia Léperon.
-Depuis son enfance,
Nathalie pratique
la course à pied à haut niveau.
Au fil des kilomètres,
cette pratique sportive est devenue
une addiction pour elle.
-En fin de semaine,
si j'étais arrivée
à 95 kilomètres,
non, je ressortais le soir
pour aller
dépasser les 100 bornes, en fait.
Quand j'avais atteint
les 100 bornes, en fait,
c'était comme un soulagement.
Là, je me dis :
"Mais comment on peut arriver
dans des états comme ça ?"
C'est là où je me dis :
"C'est une maladie."
-Exemple : actuellement,
une grave blessure
l'empêche de pratiquer
son sport favori.
Elle s'est rabattue
sur le vélo, aujourd'hui.
Pourtant,
malgré l'effort sportif,
elle a le sentiment
que quelque chose
s'est brisé dans sa vie.
-Non, c'est un réel besoin.
Il y a un manque,
et c'est très,
très dur à accepter,
en fait.
-Avec l'expérience,
Nathalie a appris
à prendre du recul.
Désormais,
elle accepte plus facilement
les mises au repos
de son corps,
car elle a pris conscience
que trop de sport
est mauvais pour sa santé.
-J'ai été beaucoup
en surentraînement,
à m'épuiser
finalement, m'épuiser
tant physiquement que mentalement,
donc j'ai quand même fait,
ce qui est très, très rare, déjà,
6 fractures de fatigue,
2 ruptures du tendon de l'insertion
et de l'ischiojambier.
J'en suis à ma 3e.
J'ai poussé mon corps à bout
depuis très, très jeune.
Donc, je pense que là,
il me dit clairement stop.
-Si aujourd'hui Nathalie arrive
à mieux doser ses entraînements,
d'autres ont toujours du mal
à y renoncer.
A Nantes, cette jeune femme
s'est découverte
récemment malade
de la pratique du sport.
Son abus est considéré
par les scientifiques
comme une addiction, au même titre
que l'alcool ou les drogues.
Les mécanismes psychiques
à l'oeuvre
seraient les mêmes.
Cependant, pour la plupart
de ces sportifs assidus,
cette addiction
est difficile à accepter.
-Mais quand j'en ai pris conscience,
ouais, ça m'a...
Ca m'a un peu embêtée
de reconnaître, en fait, que bah...
J'arrivais pas...
Je n'avais plus le contrôle,
en fait.
Oui, il y a toujours un truc
de se dire :
"Et merde !
Je croyais que j'allais gérer
"et en fait,
je gère pas beaucoup."
Comme une personne
qui est dépendante à l'alcool,
ou même au tabac.
C'est clairement une addiction
qui est valorisée.
Vaut mieux faire 10 à 15 heures
de sport par semaine
plutôt que de passer
10 à 15 heures par semaine
à boire de l'alcool
ou prendre de la cocaïne.
Il y a un côté
où les gens le valorisent.
Les gens sont là à dire :
"C'est génial,
"t'as trop de chance
d'avoir cette volonté."
Oui, mais après,
les gens voient pas forcément
que c'est pas qu'une volonté,
c'est aussi un besoin,
et qu'il y a tous...
Ouais, les mêmes choses, en fait :
la souffrance, la difficulté
à contrôler ses comportements.
-Face à ses difficultés,
elle a décidé
de se faire accompagner
en allant chaque semaine
au service
d'addictologie
du CHU de Nantes.
Le docteur Prétagut,
chef du service, s'est spécialisé
dans la prise en charge
de l'addiction au sport.
-Bonjour.
-Selon lui, cette maladie
doit être prise plus au sérieux.
-Le sport est valorisé globalement,
et donc on ne repère pas
spécifiquement cette problématique,
qui pourtant
se prend en charge
de façon assez...
Enfin, pas simple,
mais qui donne
des résultats très tôt.
-En tout cas,
faire l'autruche
ne sert à rien.
Une addiction
peut en cacher d'autres.
Il faut donc savoir
réagir vite.
-C'est bien souvent
à l'adolescence
que les problématiques d'addiction
se mettent en place,
parfois plus tard,
mais on peut passer
d'une addiction à une autre.
L'objet peut être l'alimentation
pour les troubles alimentaires,
la drogue pour les toxicomanies,
le sport dans d'autres cas.
Et donc,
au fil de sa vie,
on peut rester
sur une même addiction,
éventuellement,
la prendre en charge, c'est mieux,
ou on peut passer
d'un objet à un autre,
comme c'est le cas souvent
dans le sport.
-Certaines études scientifiques
montreraient une surreprésentation
des sportifs de haut niveau
dans les différentes catégories
d'addiction.
Etre addict au sport
serait d'autant plus néfaste
sur le long terme,
car il peut arriver
de glisser d'une addiction
à une autre.
-Guillaume,
vous avez eu une addiction ?
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Vous étiez en manque ?
Vous vous exerciez tout le temps ?
C'était quoi ?
Elle se manifestait comment ?
-Moi, quand j'étais rameur,
je m'en apercevais pas,
parce qu'on est toujours
dans cette pratique sportive,
tout le temps.
J'en ai vraiment pris conscience
quand j'ai arrêté l'aviron.
Je n'avais plus
la même dépense énergétique
et mon corps me réclamait
quelque chose.
-Vous étiez pas bien ?
Vous trembliez ?
-J'étais très vite agacé,
je transpirais,
je tremblais,
j'avais
des symptômes de manque,
et donc,
je partais courir.
Je partais courir,
faire du vélo
pour avoir de l'endorphine
et me calmer.
-Ca allait mieux ?
Ca vous calmait ?
-Oui, j'ai trouvé...
-Y compris la nuit.
-Oui, je me réveillais
et je partais courir
à 2-3h du matin.
Donc, j'en ai parlé à mon médecin
qui m'a dit :
"Guillaume, c'est une maladie
"qui touche certains sportifs."
"Ah bon, bigorexie ?"
J'avais jamais entendu.
Et donc, effectivement,
quand j'ai appris
à lire cette maladie,
effectivement,
je me retrouvais beaucoup
dans ces symptômes-là.
Donc, j'ai réussi à m'en sortir
en réduisant un peu
l'intensité
de mes entraînements.
-Parce qu'on en a tous,
autour de nous,
des joggeurs, par exemple.
Ils se sentent pas bien.
Ils se sentent pas bien le matin
s'ils vont pas courir,
faire 30 minutes,
1 heure de course.
On se dit :
"Ils sont super, quand même,
"ils courent tous les jours."
En fait, ils sont addicts.
-Oui.
Il y a plusieurs phases.
Je pense que le premier niveau,
c'est le bien-être.
On se lève, on va courir,
après,
on a l'impression
d'avoir déjà réussi sa journée.
Et après, il y a la partie
un peu plus addictive
quand on en fait
vraiment à fond tous les jours.
Là, c'est plus problématique.
-Donc, faire attention
si on se sent mal.
Vous aviez les mêmes symptômes
que quelqu'un en manque ?
-C'est ça.
-La transpiration, des tremblements.
Il fallait que vous partiez ?
-Oui.
-Intéressant. Ca va mieux ?
-Oui, très.
Ca va très bien, maintenant.
-Comme c'est la règle de l'émission,
on interpelle un député.
Vous avez posé une question
sur la prévention
de la santé mentale dans le sport.
Erwan Balanant,
député MoDem du Finistère,
vous répond.
Lui-même a été athlète
de haut niveau étant jeune.
Que proposez-vous
en termes de prévention ?
-Moi, je pense
que c'est dans le rôle,
déjà, des éducateurs sportifs,
dès le plus jeune âge,
de rappeler à l'enfant,
mais aussi aux parents,
c'est important,
que le sport,
c'est pas non plus
qu'une histoire de performance.
C'est une histoire de recherche,
de bien se sentir, d'être bien,
d'un complément
d'une activité intellectuelle
que l'on a... Voilà.
Et donc, c'est important,
aujourd'hui,
que les éducateurs soient formés
à un minimum de psychologie.
Est-ce qu'ils le sont suffisamment ?
Je suis pas complètement sûr.
Moi, j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un entraîneur
qui se préoccupait de ça,
mais je sais que j'ai des camarades
qui pouvaient être en souffrance,
parce que leurs entraîneurs
s'occupaient
de la performance athlétique.
Mais la performance athlétique,
et ça,
mon entraîneur l'avait compris,
elle ne va nulle part
si vous n'avez pas une...
Si vous êtes pas bien
dans votre tête.
-Guillaume Toucoullet,
ce que dit
Erwan Balanant,
c'est qu'il faudrait donc former
les éducateurs sportifs
à en parler aux enfants,
mais aussi aux parents.
Ca, c'est intéressant.
Que les parents préviennent
l'enfant,
soient plus attentifs aux risques
pour la santé mentale
du sport à haut niveau.
C'est une bonne idée ?
-Oui, enfin, je trouve.
Toujours faut-il
être formé à ça,
comprendre les réactions.
C'est pas non plus évident.
Notamment, quand on arrive
à l'adolescence,
il y a plein de sujets
qui perturbent les enfants
ou les ados,
donc c'est bien d'être formé aussi.
Et les éducateurs sportifs,
pour moi, c'est primordial
de les sensibiliser là-dessus.
Mais bon, j'ai bon espoir
que ce soit fait.
On en parle de plus
en plus.
-Ah bon ?
-J'espère, oui.
-Il faut en parler.
Merci !
Il faut vous dire bonne chance ?
En tout cas,
on le pense très fort.
-Merci.
-Merci,
Guillaume, d'avoir été avec nous
dans "Etat de santé".
Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA